ouch go - pair of hat and welcome back
to the wolf - that's playing we pissed
now are these our suspects no it can't
be
who the [ __ ] are they so you're blind
well you don't see there's a line I've
been standing here a half hour already I
look like a guy Shannon must be nice
being the sheriff do whatever the [ __ ]
you like yeah we're here and what great
work you do
sheriff hmm that didn't feel very
genuine [ __ ]
he's the [ __ ] you because you are the
one bringing this to me miss snow the
one who so simply stumbled upon this
catastrophe on our very doorstep she did
thousand I need what mayor Cola way is a
hysteria do you understand me yes of
course I don't interrupt me miss no you
asked me a question don't change the
subject you are to blame for this
unpleasantness miss snow I brought you
this news as soon as I could
you are trusted to keep things running
smoothly around here this is a disaster
if anyone's to blame it's me you don't
need to be yelling at her
oh you're rolling this is Julie noted
yes let's talk about that Sheriff
you are the one charged with protecting
the citizens of Fabletown your failure
to do so cost someone their life and the
safety of the entire community tell me
you've been doing something are there
any leads suspects anything anything at
all any shred of evidence you to know
what the hell you're doing
because right now I have half a mind to
fire the both of you
I don't know I don't want to give him
the mind it's his MO it's shaky but
don't be absurd Bluebeard is out of the
country as we speak so don't even think
about accusing him of such a treacherous
affair if all you're operating off of
his ancient history we're all in much
more trouble than I imagined you two
need to get a handle on this situation
quickly and quietly the last thing we
need is all a Fabletown knowing there's
a killer amongst us snow yes sir Cole
the vien right this minute and let her
know I'm coming in early for my massage
oh-ho where is the bottle of wine you
were to purchase don't bother
forget it can't do anything right the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] he's getting giant
and massaged and he tells me how to do
my job
[ __ ] you you know what stop we'll get on
it right away sir
you would have just pissed him off more
all right
thanks no well that could have gone
better
well I guess I should have listened to
you and waited wasn't gonna say I told
you so
you don't have to say it it would have
been better to have more to offer get
our ducks in a row
ducks did someone say ducks what crane
doesn't like people smoking and more for
the battery smoke away
it's the vine you out to a massage
probably a gift the weird part of that
is that he's actually been nice to
someone I know I bought that damn bottle
what the hell is gone is he gone
oh geez so ugly thankfully he got the
wife the [ __ ] buff kin hello miss no
drinking this early where did you get
that it was by mr. Ricca BOTS desk and
don't you think it probably belongs to
him maybe
monkeys aren't supposed to drink dog God
so ugly a mr. big be worse now that
you're here I'm fine bumpkin thanks for
asking
Afghan how would you remember that which
books the ones with all the fables in it
not sure that was any more specific
bring the first three be back in a few
minutes
he knows the ones I'm talking about
there's bound to be information on her
here somewhere oh so she's seen the
fable at least be able to get her real
name from the books whenever buff can
find son hmm I wonder if she around
maybe the mirror can help I really have
to get this appointment squared away but
let me know if you need anything you
bros were saying that she was the Little
Red Riding Hood don't think so magic
lamb sir pretty much just lamps after
the genies been afraid this is that the
alledon lamp huh it is isn't a this is
that the mirror from magic mirror I got
a question you know the rule uh I have
time for this ha ha ha ha your
impatience is callow you're needlessly
cruel but have some respect for our
history rules Mirror Mirror if you're
able tell me all about this fable see
was that so you have to Ryan I'm about
two seconds away from kicking a hole in
you there's no need for that
of which fable do you wish to know
that's what I don't know I guess I bad I
the woods man show me the woodsman where
is he what you see is complete the
woodsman stumbles down the street no
[ __ ]
which Street I'm sorry Big B I can only
show you what can be seen
I want that [ __ ] does that mean alright
let's go to snow and I don't eat snow
white he really loves lecture for
requiring at his face she's in this very
room well I thought I could know more
about her okay but show me buff him hey
put down the bottle and get to work
still looking hahahaha really
alright I don't know her knew her name
not yet anyway well love to do
well we'll come back for nobody right
now
very well please return should you wish
to ask about someone else or someone new
fine okay finally got the drunk ass son
of a [ __ ] idiot
I fell I'm sure we get it all cleared up
okay thank you
all right let's check out this box shall
we so this is like a database of all old
fables a tarot deck strength yes it
comes in all forms
and just
ah
can I just go over there let's
investigate the book of fables we'll
start with these any information on
fables in our community will be
somewhere in these books is that a
basketball it's pumpkin oh I know him
it's a it's a why don't I am sorry you
both tell me cuz I forgot the name since
that's snow
and her little our me that's me that's
the wood man that's our girl red
that's that Riding Hood night in shabby
armor the woodsman yep and his axe
that's but the big bad will me a good
day I'm pretty sure that's supposed to
be me
yeah dwarves I said about that the
better beauty happier days so she was
happier in the fairytale and then after
that happily ever after it's not working
out beached
is that it funny Colin and his brothers
Oh Colin is part of the three oh that's
why he ruined her house his house
hahahahahaha now I get it
I'm so stupid I've seen this before this
symbol on the man's clothes it's the
same as the Rings oh yeah father or
husband this has most of the emblems of
the old days and usually what family
they come from if it's in here we'll
have her name cool well that's a lead
can we investigate on the ring now how
do we I don't seem to know how to do
that okay well let's check the books
great what I can't read any of this [ __ ]
once can we help
yeah thanks we look out for each other
don't overdo it but translate that's
another night exquisite design from the
good China of toad ha mr. toad he
probably wrote this in himself
Berenice right now it looks like that
there it is
that was this is the one where's this
symbol from which family our story
that's an odd one family name I learn
like I love our laws every kind of fur
in German oh it's Jeremy again yes
what does it say donkey skin girl
also known as donkey skin also known as
a skin prefers to go by the name faith
poetic laughs can we don't need the
commentary the story of donkeys yet
there was once a great king with a
beautiful Queen the Queen grew ill and
had her husband promised to only marry
the most beautiful girl in the kingdom
after a long search it became clear that
the only woman in the land that could
match her beauty was Oh his daughter
faith
she had a magic cloak made from the skin
of her father's prized donkey that would
hide her beauty so she could escape his
kingdom I know this story she married a
prince who could see past the magic
cloak anew her true beauty and they
lived happily ever after huh should I
mark it miss snow yes please
dad yeah donkey skin and what's her
husband's name Lawrence Prince Lawrence
well it looks like we're gonna have a
talk to him we got what we came for
yeah her name's faith she was married to
Prince Lawrence I mean that's more than
was faith yeah we should talk to the
husband you think he did it
well we can't really Mouse me at this
point we can't rule him out right yes I
think so okay so we should go and talk
to the thing again now that we know the
fable it couldn't hurt right Mirror
Mirror bla bla able bla bla bla about
this fable ha ha ha which fable do you
wish any bricks about fail me show me
faith through powerful magic her
whereabouts concealed unfortunately for
you these lips are sea and that's the
key for these lips are sealed it's not
my choice of phrasing baby it's simply
the way this has to be so someone put a
spell on them to not talk is that it
eyes stick on French stick
show me Prince Lawrence yes Vance she's
been doing where is vaping where's what
do you know where Prince Lawrence lives
if he's a prince
probably relocated in the South Bronx
yellow building red window-shutters
red frames yep that's the one
I can take us there
just one moment I want to check on that
father kill me faith his father the old
king
no he's dead
yes that crosses him off the suspect
list well nobody right now anything we
can use
yeah it'll have to do for now come on
we're going over there health
yes what sorry I have to get that I
don't like this hello woodlands business
office yes all right hold on sorry talk
in the morning it's for you
what that fukk baby is clean oh do you
dare
what do you want what do you want big
big [ __ ] issue not as a bloke upstairs
going through all the woodsman's things
get out were a big big before I'm on
there what was that about
hard to say something going on over at
Oates place
what about faiths husband I don't know I
couldn't really tell but he could be in
trouble and we should go there anyway to
search her apartment
toad might have to wait whenever you're
ready
I'm ready breaths I don't think we
should make toad wait you're welcome
such a gentleman
did toad say Hubert was it the woodsman
I don't know it's possible whoever it
was it didn't seem like toad was happy
to see him
well maybe Prince Lawrence can wait hey
he didn't see him hmm could use some
help - well he looks dead
well where to first what are you resting
what are you resting I like your brother
sign big big issue not as a block
upstairs gonna do all the woodsman's
that you should he did it
what's her husband's name Lawrence Vince
mom ah geez I hate this sessions
all right bras hope you enjoyed this
episode I gotta let you bros decide
which one we're gonna pick toad or
Lawrence which one should we go with
first bras write a comment down below
and whatever gets the most votes we're
gonna go with that way you can't tell me
what's wrong generators wrong I don't
know what that was a sentence anyway
liver lockers no walking I really
appreciate your support
Samson buzz love you ha ha
straight okay [ __ ] is wrong with people
oh I don't think so